apriti un po fa vedere
che la seconda era l'ottava tappa
tranquilla abbiamo anche i tagli per
bambine tela vado a prendere subito vada
questa sede dice dove già finita ci sarà
mica offesa ma la belli e va da questa
sera taglia della giungla dell'edi
secondo me è per te su due piedi e
meglio di xl così emma la seconda di
questo
no in magazzino non c'è ho appena
controllato
mi dispiace a momenti mi da parte questo
è la terza cliente che me lo chiedete lo
vogliono tang economici abbiamo questa
299 questo è un euro 99 è pura viscosa
ve tranquilla ancora più economico
va in giro nuda se gratis semiveloci che
devo fare stante buoni ci siano senza
feriti alle tette cadenti come stessa
lorenzo
amore sono resistenti 5 euro 99 ad
esservi chirurgo mi associo stracca non
ce la faccio più dei fari coli vuoi
andare in pausa signora qui vitali in
cotone non li trova abbiamo solo di
scusa cento per cento ma tranquilla al
massimo ne viene un po di dermatite
niente di grave